- Tout le monde n'est pas prêt à
avouer
Bolsonaro au premier tour de
l'élection.totototototototototoe
s'en cache pas.
Il aurait préféré que Bolsonaro
gagne au premier tr. Ar. Alberto
est chauffeur d'un grand hôtel
de Rio, l'auto lui appartient.
Bolsonaro. Quatre ans plus tard,
e est satisfait. Il se dit
de droite.
Totalement de droite, mais pas
fanatique. Il ne critique ni
la gestion de la COVID par
de l'Amazonie par exemple.
"Il a réalisé de grands projet
et combattu la corruption et
le Brésil est dans le fond
plus conservateur qu'on ne
le pensait. Comme Alberto,i i it
appuyé Jair Bolsonaro, presque
la moitié, ne sont évidemment
pas d'extrême droite. Mais,nenee
d'extrême droite, qui,
selon l'ONG Open Society,
vise carrément à détruirerarara.
PEDRO VEIRA ABRAMOVAY, dir.,
Open Society Foundations
- Je crois qu'il y a un mélange
de frustrapolitique traditionne,
qui continue Bolsonaro.
Il a réussi, un peu comme
Trump, à être l'establishment
co
- Jair Bolsonaro s'attaque
de front a i institutions :
le Congrès, la Cour suprême,
le sys
de la société civile, la presse.
Il e c critiqué aussi pour avoir
facilité l'accès aux armes à
fe
chez des gens comme Alberto.
(cris de la foule)
violent, dit-il et j'ai
moi-même été agressé."
la tempe, il aurait une arme
si le permis n'était pas encore
- Et je crois que cette
po
forte entre Bolsonaro et Lula.
AÀ l'élection de 2018, Pedro
Abramovay nous avait dit que
- Il est encore plus dangereux
exactement parce que ses
collègues, pour ainsi dire,
enfin, Ortega, enfin, dans
plusieurs contextes différents,
ils ont un... quand on voitanann
voyait encore les institutnsns
démocratiques fonctionner.
la Hongrie, la Turquie,
le Nicaragua, entre autres,
ont pris le virage autoritaire.
la trajectoire du Brésil.
Le Brésil doit décider le
30 octobre si on va rétablir le.
- Les institutions brésiliennes
pourraient-elles résister à un
deuxième manda
En tout cas, au deuxième tour
le 30 octobre, Jair Bolsonaro
aura une forte pente à remonter
s'il ne veut pas devenir
le premier président du Brésil
moderne a raté sa réélection.
Et dans ce cas, comme aux
États-Unis, le Trump tropical
acceptera-t-il la défaite?
Rien n'est garanti.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Rio de Janeir